louder with Crowder studios protected
exclusively by Walter and hopper
who's the head honcho around here oh
yeah sir my name is steven crowder and
these here are the Mudd Club Z's from
Liederkranz late-night comedy of
salvation to south of Seoul and we hear
you might have a platform for us to
upload our videos to well that out of
hands you boys do conservative videos
sir we are cub let's all accept our
comeback are coming up all accept our
half asian boy you're standing in the
corner over there well I really don't do
conservative videos I'm looking for more
sjw social and material well we're just
it started featuring five Young Turk
videos every day
the platform and everybody else so
thanks for stopping by sermo club a lot
of Crider been steeped in socialism heck
you silly win maybe see ya later that's
right
we ain't really conservative I'll accept
that half-asian lawyer stand in the
corner over there in constant sorrow its
seizure
stay
[Music]
but shadow would be monetized
notifications or / 4-day notifications
100
[Music]
three long
years I've been in trouble shadow brain
[Applause]
for Susan which is
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
I hired a man
half Asia he practiced wah that's what
they see
[Music]
he sticks it
those big dick kids he puts the lid
people
[Music]
[Applause]
and demonetised
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
that's called AI actually a full-grown
male friend who would eat with a spoon
like this no one had ever taught him
this because these parents were
imprisoned you Josh we have Anthony ku
Mia you won't be getting gifts for
Christmas
Anthony ku Mia on the show today Ted
Cruz will be back later in junior to
reschedule college eyes Hedy ah we have
a seven plus one today should use to get
to a be discussing universal basic
income before introduce everybody let me
ask you this are you worried about
automation technology killing jobs
what's your biggest employment concern
going forward that will determine
hopefully kind of where you line up in
universal basic income and how old are
you we realize we have enough people
watching this that we can do actual
polls with legitimate sample sizing
that's true quarterblack Garrity's do we
have audio Wade half-asian lawyer bill
Richman is here because we're gonna get
copyright struck anyway so we'll have
them around it's just really just like a
speed dial in person a pent Ellis is
here to drink no in podcast don't happen
to be back glad to have you in G Morgan
Jr one of the day one of the day is
palermo palermo can't get this guy on
the front has a universal basic income -
what does I don't see they're kind of
dead yeah kind of like your bet we
should cancel one of my there's no
reason for it is this guy drink they're
always empty when he brings them yeah
the studio just chuggin yeah
which also makes it even more
uncomfortable because that means here e
corks it sour grapes dare you say all
Asians yeah I don't trust them don't use
that sorry sorry I only trust the good
half it's kind of like one of the Olsen
twins once this all right I just wasted
all right leading the news Democratic
frontrunner of course Joe Biden he was
being the American Federation of
Teachers and he forgot his pledge to
apparently respect person is dangerous
idea you know as these guys will tell
you I'm not always their favorite
subject it's like a Swedish guy with a
biracial child we actually um we
obtained exclusive audio as intercepted
by Vice President Biden's earpiece and
it seems things only got worse for the
control-room ooh I'll bet you're as
bright as your good-looking
okay Vice President Biden that's great
turn on the camera journalism
oh okay Joe seems like she's a college
student that's great really to pick up
the college vote please let's get a
clear shot of her camera number four
okay great Joe bring it to where we can
see her on camera and oh okay well she's
a little girl let's joke get off of it
get off of it let's get off just no
don't don't don't go please Joe Joe get
off there was unnecessary that's like
you can't control himself you really I
know I shouldn't do this but she's so
fly oh my gosh what's the over-under on
how many times he's gonna do this like
the guy knows every camera in the room
is on him and he still can't help y'all
back in Chains in a sex dungeon it is
disgusting dang Berg RBG
as they call her Netflix root baby she
came out the other day and should the
pregnant women are not mothers oh wow
yeah and Ginsburg's descent on box vs.
Planned Parenthood Indiana Kentucky she
wrote quote a woman who exercises her
constitutionally protected right to
terminate a pregnancy is not a mother
this is in response to Clarence Thomas
you probably know this they're a half
Asian bill you're probably a fan of but
following the laws yeah you would think
so when reached actually for further
comment
the Justice couldn't provide any because
she's dead oh yeah CNN's Jim Acosta
is that that's not to slander libel
isn't there build she's actually mean so
many things like she's actually dead
right I think so yes I mean she looks
she looks like a cartoon snail librarian
she's hiding under the robes a large
large appendage librarian I'm going to
making a trip to Colorado's magic he
doesn't need to is in Montreal those
machines it's everywhere little rooster
egg roosters don't lay eggs I don't care
show's already gone off the rails no
that's Julie Jim Acosta he's had
declared that media neutrality is no
longer a possibility under President
Trump this comes from his new book the
enemy of the people a dangerous time to
tell the to truth in America I'm still
laughing at the snail lighter when
reached for comment the head of CNN's
Pakistan bureau was being beheaded so
and he admitted Acosta he admitted to
grandstanding and showboating by the way
contradicting literally everyone in the
media
who's defended Acosta president-elect
Trump today told CNN's Jim Acosta that
his organization amounts to fake news
yes it is our observation that it's
correspondents follow journalistic
standards that neither they nor any
other journalists should be subjected to
belittling and D legitimizing by the
president-elect of the United Nation
from Baghdad and he actually went to
Cuba on Cuban soil and pres Raul Castro
about the human rights violation this is
what he does and this is what a great
reporter knuckle in go ahead Peter Gunn
in Jim's defense I've traveled with him
and watched him he's a diligent reporter
who busts I'm not a big fan of yours
either does he now say that he needs to
grandstand and lie or does he always did
he always do that or just because the
president basically called the book I
don't know about all this you know look
the unbiased truth would help here just
a little bit right if that's what we
were getting we're not saying that this
is Nazi Germany and you can't have an
opinion right just saying that you're
very biased yeah well Helen Thomas would
like it to be Nazi Germany send send the
Jews back no do you never know that no
one remembers us I do remember what
Helen Thomas you know Merce they should
go back to Poland
you crazy old it's amazing to me the in
bigness the indignance of these people
that's like saying hey I think your
neighbor might be a pedophile sick how
dare you I may be fixed with kids there
is that but Brooks what just I mean it's
literally like you watched leaving
leaving Neverland which i think is like
a quote yeah that pretty much what they
wrote a book though cuz he has no Chris
so unfunny it's like if plywood wrote a
book at the brain of the world it's a
two-by-four just play you have a great
alright switch an international news a
church offered to cover up a cross in
the image of Jesus for Ramadan going
back to the original reason for church
to appease the guy who said that Christ
lied about pretty much everything
there's a wrong yeah you would think the
plan was to quote invite men from a
nearby mosque to use the church as a
place of prayers happened of course
across the pond
I think joining us on the line right now
is the Church of England pastor Reverend
Nigel Smith to to discuss it right
Reverend Smith are you there yes Stephen
thank you for having me I appreciate
the rails didn't take much time should
have seen it coming couldn't have landed
anywhere the way um no problem boats
doing the math mad
there was no other way than zero for
shame on you for sanctions so finally
this is our final struggle bring us to 7
plus 1 then talking about universal
basic income which I'm sure a lot of you
support because you're Millennials and
though even though you're conservative
your desire for free stuff put us all on
the same precedes it I put in that exact
same bucket I'm juggling a bucket Wow oh
yeah it's true the young gang finally
the best and most dangerous dumpling the
initiation is voting for somebody who
gets zero percent of the Democratic
feeling his gran torino I don't know why
they had all those kids to act now that
is a proof positive that Asians can't
act sorry bill what is it a question is
recently this video where they did this
parody of Aladdin and hoping for a
diverse cast hoping for more Asian
actors oh they're going like listen at a
certain point there has to be a
meritocracy well you hear
oscar-nominated films and that's a
really shadow category with foreign it's
still embarrassing it wasn't it wasn't a
parody it came out last week
yes theaters yeah real okay I won't take
this just a real quick point however
Keanu Reeves this part Asian oh that's
true do not even talk about
I know nationalists renewing his
favorite film is Bill Richmond bill
half-asian Larry bel-ridge mo I'm proud
to say it's Constantine no your number
one is the prestige oh yeah and number
two is Constantine top five is
Constantine German show number one
prestige why explain your rationale who
hugh jackman man he is amazing yeah I
mean I liked him in the greatest showman
he had a quite a voice okay and then
explained constant about Wolverine I
mean it's just I don't know it's wack it
doesn't make any sense horrible taste
not clearly is that okay we have to get
to another Church story a church they
agreed to host drag queen storytime Oh
after the City Library canceled the
event this is where Ryan Hart comes in
he's the pastor of a church that decided
to rent out a room at the library for
the event I thought well why can't our
church just hosted my reasoning and the
reasoning of open Cathedral and having
this event is to keep kids safe and kids
are safer when they know that they can
love themselves we should point out the
event was canceled after drag queen
storytime in Houston was found to have
hired registered sex offender yes you
have to cover-up Jesus and invited on
and dragged away story time did you guys
do a Bible study this week seven plus
one they always forget the one immature
seven plus one top drag queen story time
books the most popular stories that they
read to children at these events that's
good we'll all have a chance number
seven Harry Potter and the Sex Prisoner
of Azkaban number six by Curious George
which pen tell us it with number five
again top drag queen story books for
children yes all the places you'll go
hmm just don't tell your parents my
lawyer takes a sip of his water yeah
let's all get our hands dirty
number four half-asian bill the grooming
tree oh that was it number number three
in case we hadn't lost the remaining
half of you if you give a mouse a butt
plug yeah this is not a power it's the
drag queen story sawdust
perverse who would do that report it
yeah you're letting this new church
Gerald give us number two James this
giant it's like a Georgia O'Keeffe
painting right this because we're going
on a theme and the number one drag queen
storytime book pent Ellis the little
engine that could keep his mouth shut
yeah that seems almost I apologize yeah
you in there
it's not that was them it was not us we
just have to tell you guys you know
these aren't the books that are getting
banned with local libraries right no
they are the ones that it's definitely
nothing not from the local hospital that
was hilarious the guy was like I know
children are safer when they can
[Music]
okay ready
[Music]
sorry Rhett sitting on their half-asian
bill before that necessary break it's
all ball bearings house Clark if you see
women out there if you uh if you're
dating a guy who uses a fidget spitter
kill him again question of the day is
what's your view on universal basic
income I know some conservatives have
actually supported this but I think it
needs to be understood contextually as
to suck why some might I will say this
there is a scenario where I could be on
board with it but back to you guys what
your the question I want to hear
answered from you how concerned are you
about automation and how old are you
what's your be is concerned getting into
the job market that seems to be why this
is gaining a lot of traction universal
basic income of course you have the yang
gang bill who knows and quartz has
talking about it
[Applause]
universal basic income is a policy where
every citizen in a country gets a
certain amount of money to meet his or
her basic needs no questions asked so in
my plan the freedom dividend every
American adult could receive one
thousand dollars a month starting at age
eighteen you know your you know your
robotic when they spruce your interview
up with a xylophone
[Laughter]
wait so for people who don't know
universities can come as Andrew yang is
proposing is a thousand dollars a month
for every American citizen period that's
the idea fun lot of taxpayers cory
booker Kamala Harris have been pushing
similar plans yeah and then of course
the wonderful now this news they
recently published a video explaining
why it's a great idea spoiler I disagree
but let's go to the tale the tape from
now this I believe we need a universal
basic income and
it's taste universal basic income is a
direct cash transfer that is we give
people a set amount of money per month
no strings at a four people be free to
buy groceries diapers pay rent say for
an emergency crack pay for medical care
or simply take their family to movie
crack heroin methamphetamine you can't
get a tax deduction which would
essentially be putting cash in your
pockets not as you can use cash instead
buy drugs this would be great this would
not be a good day actually for Asians
you have the first yang and then that
guy not Indian assume that soon I think
no no no I'm the end there the yang is
this how it works on the other side of
the coin careful Gerald's gonna try and
get in on that action and say something
funny so before we get to the untenable
position under burden for the argument
let me ask you a few questions here okay
because the economics were again they
don't provide any any statistics or data
we'll do our course to try and fill in
the blanks thanks now this like 50
million players on Facebook it's just
claimed lately empty Claro let's just
walk you through the logic trail first
okay a couple of questions to credit
method you give every $1,000 no
questions asked okay do you think that
would make most citizens more or less
likely to save do you think that would
encourage people to be more or less
likely to plan for retirement more or
less likely to strive for a better job
and achieve some kind of social mobility
this these are the first questions you
need to answer yeah and and by the way
you can never ever ever end it
government programs are notoriously hard
are you Taylor Swift right and you can't
end it right and more it's more likely
to increase so let's say we started
$1,000 the next guy is gonna come along
because I want to get elected by giving
people free stuff let's give them 1200
bucks a month yeah I'm better than that
guy imagine that in stating a thousand
dollars for every single person and then
Burnie at the tiller of that ship yeah
thousand dollar month universal basic
income has not increased with inflation
[ __ ] yes exactly it's like fight for 15
this would happen I have an idea what if
you could tell me if there's if this
makes any sense it doesn't what what if
instead of giving people random
like $1,000 one of you just lower taxes
in these big areas so they would have
$1,000 more at the end of it getting
that money the government you just cut
off our future now this clip at the
knees you should watch first because
they left that they don't want to do
that you'd want to cut back so they
address it very effectively your
argument is mute mute it's moot I know
it's moot accidentally said mute okay
get off my back it's mopes by the way
hit the notification bail because
subscriptions don't mean anything
apparently bill thinks his client is
very unstable right now hat invasion
little bit no more than normal half
asian mother and by the way bookmark the
page because I've been hit with the yeah
the false copyrights iTunes leave us a
rating alright
point number two this is something that
this is these are sort of I guess this
is one of the premises that they base
the universal basic income yeah so
instead of point let's say these are
kind of the tenants of what they believe
here by the way I didn't say 10 min says
and renters I don't want it the last
thing I want is to be in a solar on
deadline you know he said nope I am
being vilified while the pedophile gets
a parade I've already kind about
literally bill clean it up in a release
after trust me you're in good hands okay
they make the argument that work doesn't
work doesn't pay people often work one
two or three jobs and still live in
poverty in fact work pays so little that
a majority of Americans don't have a
thousand dollars in the bank for an
emergency ninety-five million Americans
live in poverty and one in three parents
can't afford diapers for their children
first we have to recognize that work
doesn't pay no matter how long and how
much people work they're not getting by
and they're certainly not getting at so
first you have to listen to me when I
repeat these completely empty claims
right for step two
see step one correct but they claim
Americans work two three jobs
ninety-five there's again there's
nothing in that claim I could not find
any statistic that reflects ninety-five
million Americans living in poverty
working multiple jobs is tamale falls
the number is thirty nine point seven
million according to the ultra bias US
cents
I want to make sure you understand this
is the modern-day Herod headcount are
you hit your lighter say alright
anything you're just I didn't it was the
lawyer talking about poverty again is
thirty nine million it's not ninety five
million yeah again this changes it right
if you think someone's working three
jobs and 95 million being three jobs are
in poverty numbers actually under forty
million and by the way the standards of
poverty in it
they have multiple vehicles air
conditioning y screen TVs passed
Internet I understand it's widescreen I
said Y screen by the way it was nice
that they didn't have any kind of tech I
even looked at the very bottom there was
no source listed for the ninety five of
course right now this when you go away
can you let's now that it's not it's not
about just material goods you would've
at any of those things if you're the
wealthiest person on earth eighty years
ago people say oh that doesn't so you're
saying because they have an iPhone it's
not hard no I'm talking about the kinds
of opportunities afforded to everyone
because of advancements in technology
I've used this example before imagine if
you could go back into the Civil War
tyrannous fantasies a kid like yeah I
can go back with an m16 and grenade
launcher okay by hopper jerk no one will
be able to stand a chance yeah now he's
back bills they serve you Oh
best of all is dedicated to you this
show is not a good one video will we
will see in our analytics that's the
portion that everyone will rewind yeah
how much work we put in
dogs and monkeys it's true let's just go
a little bit more recent 25 years with
an iPhone oh yeah okay you could be more
productive than Bill Gates along with
the entire staff of Bill Gates you can
be more productive than all of them it's
not that you have a cellphone or a
microwave but you have access to
technology that gives you more
opportunities and more abilities to make
efficient use of your time and advance
your financial your social your
educational status that's the point that
we're talking about here yeah and all of
this is built on this false premise that
all work is equal Freddie saying all
this work doesn't pay well some some
jobs don't pay very well they're meant
to be entry-level jobs for you to work
up to other jobs right if you don't like
it go out and get the skills that are
required to get to a different job if
that requires you to work two jobs
sometimes you have to do that I
understand that but not all work pretty
new what else is there transit oh that's
because you're you're an elitist no no
for a second no trash men jobs pay
better you think it's beneath you
right exactly being a shift manager at a
fast-food franchise pays better you
think it's beneath you
we're telling you there's a job surplus
a lot of them but they don't know pay
super well not all of them but some of
them do yeah yeah the whole premise is
that we've you produced something and
they're gonna argue with this left and
right if you can produce something
valuable with your time then I will give
you my money right that I have earned to
do it for me and they go on to make that
point that of many Americans don't have
a thousand dollars in their saving
account right and this is evidence of
working not paying this is emblematic of
the leftists at now this because like
many of the proposed tax plans and
economic plans coming from the left it
doesn't take into account autonomic what
what meant what I think we lost half a
gene Valois you're not playing with them
you're put on the dry run and stop it a
rocky sauce it doesn't take into account
everyone understand I was to make this
point again there's all let you know in
what scenario I would be supportive of a
universal basic income but it's not
based on these false premises like right
now here I think is a still now this
yeah this is now more unfortunately we
give corporations they say free money
but not the poor but then why are we so
reticent to give people money well
in the United States we wrongfully
believed that if we help struggling
people and communities that they'll
never help themselves instead we give
big corporations and billionaires what's
right because we believe their wealth
creates deserving us so we keep giving
more what what is there any source any
evidence for that claim first up it's
not remotely true that the United States
gives nothing to the poor
currently drop about one trillion
dollars a year okay Steven that's
nothing I know it's drop in the bucket
to you do green deal I mean that's
basically that's just half a paragraph
that's two lines farting cows it's it
they don't explain what they mean by
give billionaires free money if they're
talking about government subsidies loans
for giving out money to corporations
right I'm against that every single
conservative I know is against bailout
money everyone here show of hands that
the Shogun's you know no one hears oh
okay good we shouldn't find some common
ground now that would be a good example
Obama give me five hundred thirty five
million dollars to a solar energy
company Claire bankruptcy without
actually creating anything subsidizing
great energy to the tune of thirty nine
billion dollars a year I think we all
have problems that the G the auto
bailout but don't think people need to
understand that a subsidy is very
different from a tax break yeah from
saying okay we are going to not punish
you as much if you bring these jobs or
you conduct this research on shore here
yes
that's not the same as giving somebody
money I think we need to understand the
difference and you must deal with that
all the time and business law they're
half-asian bill well I mean you gotta
think about what is the theory of if
you're gonna give someone money versus
you're gonna you know let's say a tax
break or something like that like it's
almost as if they're saying well it
doesn't matter what form you give it in
as long as you give it there's no
consequence right you just give the
money and everything will be fine but
there's no what is the empirical data to
support that this money's gonna go in
the right place we're actually change
anything right drive this point home by
the way
but this killed Mitt Romney's campaign
but it was accurate almost half of all
American don't pay federal income tax
and here's something even more than I
wish you would have clarified if you
look at income and taxes paid okay and
you take into account federal transfers
that's a word they used right look the
one trillion government programs that I
mentioned earlier meaning what you give
to people welfare food stamps the bottom
20% what would you think the bottom 20%
the United States pay a lot of people
say well they should pay less
okay so you think they're paying too
much what would be fair should they pay
20 percent 15 percent 10 percent 2
percent they pay negative 58 percent
now you take into account what's they
get in the form of transfers the next
income brackets all the way up to the
middle 20 but they all get double digits
of a negative tax rate Wow people on top
tax bracket they pay over 30 percent and
this is why whenever someone says well
this is a tax cut for the rich well yeah
because they're the only one paying
taxes and by the way top 20% of some
like 70 80 thousand dollars in a joint
income household it's not that much so
I'm important under this is a tax break
for the wealthy
well you getting you paid negative 50
yeah and your cool would you like
negative a hundred percent I don't know
I don't what do we have to do to make
you happy and you're right the only
people that can pay taxes are the people
that are earning an income to do a herb
sorry that only can get a tax break or
the ones that are paying taxes so with
the corporations when you look at them
they always paint them as this big evil
villain we shouldn't give them any tax
breaks that's how you compete for their
business yeah they can locate wherever
they would like a OC thanks for the
Amazon 25,000 jobs billions of dollars
later that's how this works
they didn't painting in corporate tax
what about the income tax yeah there
were billions of dollars paid to the
government in taxes payroll taxes that
they would have been paying in New
York's life it's one of the biggest lies
go just just for Google okay don't
YouTube search because I won't show up
when I'm to be targeted road I'm sure do
you monetize dog we're we dealt with the
the biggest myths of the rich corporate
the rich in corporations not paying
anything it's not true than Amazon has
paid nothing in taxes that's billions of
dollars annually in the last few years
ha all right another sort of one of the
fulcrum to their argument here is is
that universal basic income will boost
the economy here's how they explained I
believe we can lift millions of people
out of poverty with the universal basic
income and give people the independence
they deserve with a monthly cash
disbursement Brigante equal cash will
create an economic starless when you
give people money they spend the money
which helps boost small business and
government revenues recent Nobel
prize-winning work suggests that the
best way to reduce poverty and
is to actually give them agency this
means giving people money you give well
for perspective the federal government
just give people agency by giving how
about you give people agency by taking
money good place to say trickle-down
economics doesn't work where the ideas
if people would keep more money we're
not just talking what the wealthy but
the idea people don't understand when
you look at economists like art Laffer
the more people keep the more they will
spend what you are saying is take take
take don't let them keep her and then
give them money to spend you acknowledge
that if people have more pocket change
they'll spend it that's good for the
economy but you believe it you give
people agency by taking they're saying
by the way here's a little bit of your
back yeah you should be happy with that
by the way let's change it from
universal basic income this is wealth
redistribution period yeah course all it
is is taking from somebody else that has
a lot and giving it to someone who
doesn't like it it doesn't take into
account human nature in the Nelson a new
idea from 1968 to 1980 the USA actually
led a few trials I think they called one
of these programs a negative income tax
there's some clever lay there what did
it and what did they find
you guys know what they found they found
if you gave people free money surprise
they work dramatically less among men
43% less and they were far more likely
to be unemployed surprise were fooled
said he actually said will collect more
this money and give it to the government
but the government's already giving this
money out here what are you talking
about we want more monies hey there was
something true he said there though what
oh they're gonna give the money and then
it's gonna boost small businesses and
drug dealers are small businesses sure
so I we got in the lottery yeah every
thousand dollar ticket there's a magic
mushroom shop owner in Colorado going
[Applause]
[Laughter]
the idea that they claim that the only
way to make people independent is to
give them it made people more dependent
I just okay in order to wean your son
off of recipe and the solid food you're
gonna keep your his mouth forever
he seems like a plan on the bread okay
and by the way the argument they often
bring up I hear this a lot is yanking
you know you know what I'm talking about
they're happy oh yeah they say they use
Alaska as an example yeah this is
something a lot of people what about
Alaska I can always eat in the comments
section
hold on you might want to delete that
comment you left four minutes ago it's a
very small amount in Alaska between
three hundred two thousand dollars a
year so yeah by the way if we needed any
other examples for this this works
really well with the Native American
population very very well yeah
great results at full employment
everybody's doing well it's fantastic
just look at Steven Segal one also black
from Brooklyn ended you from Detroit
police officer yes I'm supposed to say
Mason if you look at places that have
done it on a larger scale like Canada
Finland they actually implemented
implemented get off my back universe
it's a bad program I like this it's like
a soul sleep
yeah I know the metal scenes there in
Canada Finland it failed they were set
to run a program in Canada I think for
three years I should just look at the
overlay I had to be shut down after
fifteen months well Jake is in the mail
sir sorry in the program didn't help
people get back to work have a direct
quote from the Finnish I don't know how
to do Finnish accent because they're
insignificant on a global scale no one
cares about you when people when
compared to a control group who were not
receiving the basic income the test
subjects given the money were not
significantly more likely to have gotten
back into him
just sit around I know
also unfortunately for them the people
at the end of the study were murdered by
everyone in the control group oh that
would affect it the people who had their
autonomy actually violated what their
stuff taken right they killed them seems
reasonable Finland I guess you have a
new thing to be known for so it's not a
bad bet the next point this is one
that's really bacon and it's not
ill-founded completely automation yeah
right any Americans even those with
six-figure incomes are living check to
check and third gains and productivity
are being realized by average Americans
they're being hoarded by a few people
that top automation and artificial
intelligence will only accelerate this
trend I love they're just tossing
automation and artificial intelligence
alcohol a second we've seen automation
really going back to the Agricultural
Revolution
you want people plowing fields with
spoons right there's always been
something to do that and then you got
the Industrial Revolution absolutely but
then he just throws in a I feel like
what Alexa no argument there is to say
well yeah if you want to just create
jobs and artificially create a market
just start destroying all computers you
know I should also do no electric grid
yeah candle makers man that industry is
gonna boom I mean but you can
artificially create that or you can set
up a system that it deals with important
education items encouraging people to
actually work and to be able to have the
kind of persistence going to earn them
to type money that they're interested in
that's not to say that we can entirely
eliminate poverty but how is going to
give this additional money to people who
are definitively based on the studies
not going to do anything to change their
circumstance gonna change anything and
that's what's lacking in the entire
that's a valid point can't automate this
counterpoint they would like to see
whitehouse.gov/live or front for Etsy
tree also wonderful here's something
else that people don't talk about
despite automation right there's more
probably than a bird
unemployment's at its lowest in 50 years
record number of workers entering the
workforce we have a high labor force
participation we have a job surplus and
the hard data shows us that the digital
revolution has created far more jobs
than it ever destroyed think about it
you have entire businesses that just
create apps yeah and then you have
entire businesses that just help them
code those apps and now you have entire
businesses
even just take me into account Amazon
people think it's this one Leviathan
well it is but there are it's basically
a main portal as a digital storefront
for all kinds of third-party sellers
it's sort of become the new general
store it all comes full circle this is
what people don't take into account now
I understand that some people will lose
jobs in a shifting economy and it
shouldn't be insensitive to that but
like you said we can't solve it by just
being inefficient or giving people
something that they haven't earned but
Steven what about the laserdisc
manufacturers yes no one here is crying
about track and you know your plan
doesn't address those vintage amazing
historic past how far do you take it
okay what about the key grips on route
66 work for a while where's the soda
fountain guys nobody jerked a soda like
Patrick whoa also turned out he was a
pedophile that surprised us soda
came out of nowhere the library always
up the trail which one is a nonfiction
section I tell ya another consistent
trend by the way is it get off my back
dangerous low-paying jobs have decreased
while safer high-paying jobs increase so
not only more jobs overall also a better
quality of life with the new job and
it's a reasonable conversation happen
but the problem is that technology you
can't stop it right people I just
thought of this Pol Pot had this idea I
mean the Khmer Rouge inque yeah right no
his idea was seriously his idea was full
labor everybody go out in the fields
every smart person in the country was
killed teachers people had glasses
lawyers sorry bill you guys are usually
different people have glass France where
he was in school he's like well they
must be smart no cause of their
masturbatory he's like look geniuses
like this right they basically pushed
everybody out into the the rice fields
to have them just make a an agriculture
economy that would rule the world
essentially and it miserably failed
millions of people died you know because
he tried to do that that's putting
everybody at work that's full employment
this idea has been floated before just
check history yeah well I think you know
I wasn't using Canada and Finland as
sort of benchmarks there you went
straight to Pol Pot
oh well he said I was just thinking
about this way I know every time I don't
says hey I just thought of this it's
like don't yeah I've seen it I've been
in those fields I've been in the high
school where they killed people it was
crazy but it was probably been there
more than half asian bill Richman who's
been Asia no but I was a sex tour I've
been to my mom recognize yeah I actually
helped set up a fight he has the
Thailand pre-check no no I actually
helped fight human trafficking and
program in Siem Reap no I feel yeah
what's it called
Siem Reap was the the city in northern
Cambodia and sehun Oakville - over on
the coast
Samri was actually the name of the
[ __ ] no he's mispronouncing it's Siem
Reap oh gosh Morgan Jr I understand the
appeal by the way um two small
government conservatives this is one
thing so if you were to make this
argument and I've heard conservative I
think even um if you go back I think
Friedman might have talked about this or
Hayek if you were to say let's do away
with all welfare programs also actually
gonna do away with EBT let's do away
with Social Security let's do away with
Medicare Medicaid let's do away with
welfare let's do it with all of it and
just put $1,000 into every American's
pocket regardless of income I understand
the appeal because at that point it
would save us money and you wouldn't
have the kind of government incentives
that create baby momma's at that point
you actually a government incentive to
have a joint household okay a mom in the
house 12,000 a dad and a mom 24,000 I
understand the appeal to it but that's
not what any Democrat is proposing right
this is this is very important to note
they're just saying we want to give
people money and by the way if they're
getting more on benefits already we're
going to let them keep those benefits
that's a problem yeah nobody's gonna
make that change and by the way this
program would cost that you would have
to raise right additional three trillion
dollars per year if everybody over 18
received $1,000 a month no matter their
income level and that's what the
proposal is I would sign up for the the
green New Deal much faster that's much
more plausible than doing that
no way three trillion dollars per year
yeah and they sounds like a lot grow as
the population grows I on the show bet
you we could put them home let me sure I
understand I just assumed that this plan
wouldn't be so stupid as to say we're
gonna take twelve hundred dollars from a
bunch of people and then we're just
gonna give them twelve hundred dollars
back like I'm pretty sure that's just
like a cheque floating ski now I get it
they're gonna take more from a higher
you know there's gonna higher tax rate
it's gonna redistribute but but
ultimately again like look at that
figure sixteen to eighteen thousand
dollars of a benefit already right yeah
right and so you can add on top of that
so you have to say that I'm gonna
increase by this kind of single or maybe
low double-digit change and that's
what's gonna make a big difference and
and you just don't see the evidence no
and what they say is well we would count
it as a credit so in other words if
someone gets twelve thousand dollars a
year it's a thousand dollars a month if
someone gets $1,000 a month twelve
thousand a year and they only get they
get sixteen thousand dollars of
transfers well now they would only get
four thousand dollars of turns out but
it's not like that the wash just it's
just worse on the transfers and a bunch
of people who don't need the thousand
dollars getting a thousand dollars right
and this is by the way that we do have
to get going dancing you communica this
is based on marxist theory which is all
about the abuse of the worker at the
hands of the capitalist quasi see don't
you don't need to Canadians know let me
ask what do you think the result of
having policies were those who work and
contribute to have their money taken
from them and it's given to those who
don't
how would that not eventually start a
civil war honestly it you know who's
going to win that war the ones who've
been contributing also because they're
the ones who have the guns you would
assume the kinds of people who would
purchase gonna say this is the idea that
the wealthy don't pay enough meaning
people who have over seventy eighty they
do they pay far more people in the
bottom 20% paying net negative and this
idea is that it would provide some kind
of more autonomy it doesn't it creates
slaves to the government who can then
decide what you do and when you do with
your money I'm not on board uh oh you
can't no way that's right we have one
more um we have one more story lena
dunham actually posted this photo
encouraging people to love themselves
again curb laughs what's happening
No
[Music]
hey I'm amazed I'm singing the original
song now this always happens I'm
listening to it then I forget all right
[Music]
there's no man's just a show what do you
need besides a miracle
guns lots of them
[Music]
I'm Trinity no you can tell us your
Trinity is that all you need
yeah this is the new wall through all
steel frame q5 match red dot ready it is
all I need the all steel Walter q5 match
it has good balance and a five point six
pound trigger pull
try the Walther
[Music]
apparently this was popularized by
Justin Bieber did you know oh yeah
fellow Canadian there yeah so there you
go
Celine Dion and Justin Bieber and you
work for actually for with a lot with do
you work for our next guest yeah I do
actually yeah okay from it it's not
insulting for me to say that you work
for me no no no what would it be that
you are his subordinate that you're his
Greek Montreal subordinate you know I'm
from compound media that's Rican watch
to drink minimum
and right now there's a promo code
actually a compound 24 20 percent off
you can follow him on Twitter at the qu
Mia show Anthony come here thank you for
being back sir
thank you mr. Crowder always a pleasure
to do your program I heard right off the
bat I got to talk about the Walter I
love the Walters yes they and and that
one I I have a ppk/s and I've noticed
one thing in in my situation I tend to
date girls that are a little what's the
word insane yes so this has been well
documented in the press by the way it
really has and I've noticed that the the
walther ppk/s they can barely pull that
slide back yes so it's a good gun to
have a rest
suiting you right okay the equivalent to
Steve Martin's Cork on his fork and
dirty rotten scoundrel the first thing
you do with a girl when you first meet a
girl and start going out with her is
hand are various pistols that you have
and ask her to racket the one she can
track is the one you carry around with
you that's also why by the way everyone
everyone needs to avoid the Walther CC p
that was one of its design patents
because it's a gas to later go back so
that's what my mom has it's really easy
to rack so I stay away from her when
she's upset
first question Anthony do you dye your
hair because I'm you know I'm going gray
here and it you know you've got the the
Elvis Presley jet dark black it looks
like I usually go to this place in New
York City called John Suhag very classy
joint but I decided to try a new place
out on Long Island and I get the cut and
guess I do get it colored but usually at
John Suhag they're a little more subtle
about it this one was she just gave me
the 19
77 Tony Manero so you know I little
while it starts growing I get a few
Paulie walnuts going here from The
Sopranos it was but if it was between
that and the rich little by the way
how's your Reagan impression
yes well like I had to have my hair done
it with yeah that's actually better than
rich little and not as sad rich little
we me and Jim Norton called Liam Neeson
dyes his hair for all of his taken
movies and it looks like he literally
just dipped his head in soy sauce I got
this time around with this sauce it
looks good and it's you know it's higher
not high in tight but tight but I knew a
guy at church one time who he had fully
gray hair and then came in and it was
bright and blonde and the weird thing is
you know he had a decision to make at
some point where he's going I'm just
gonna have to cross over and hope no one
will notice because he wasn't going just
for Manning and then oh it was just
great blonde and we had we didn't notice
yeah that's like Elton John did with his
wig he was bald and then one day he just
put this rat on his head and he's had it
ever since and we kind of got used to it
so yeah or like Steven Seagal with a
hair plugs oh my you can watch his
really movies like we've seen the film
like sometimes it doesn't require any
digging and it also changes based on
what ethnicity he's claiming that day so
like when he's saying I'm Native
American you know he gets the widow's
peak then he's a guy he's dead alright
the blacks in Brooklyn and then he gets
a perm and you're like I guess people
have gotten the hair plugs or
transplants or whatever you want to call
it early on because they go bald earlier
in their life and then everything else
falls out except for where they blogs in
like if you're in your 40s or something
and you're thinning and want to get get
it taken care of that's not a problem if
you're that guy that in high school
started going bald
just accept it yeah I know it's also
they're taken when you think about it
they're taking a gamble like Bosley when
they're you're basically a walking
billboard because if you go out and they
they don't have control of whether you
lose your hair or not and you tell
everyone like yeah this is Bosley
everyone it's for
more hair totter so I really I'm gonna
be very selective it would be like the
cop the college combine for people to be
had if I gave him ply think about it
yeah you got great head of hair on
yourself there thank you it's good in
the mr. fantastic going gray so that's
always asking you know my wife doesn't
like the gray but I feel you know I
think of like battle scars from the
Liberals doing it to you it's the
Liberals making your hair gray Britain's
great overnight pretty main speaking
which now we have to get back on track
what do you make of Muller's press
conference here this week I know you've
been talk this guy we all had this
amazing kind of preconceived notion
about him that he was the the man behind
the curtain the the intelligent man in
the cave on the hill or something
because we didn't wear a horse I can
rock where do you come from that
intelligent men live in caves on hills
it turned out to be a computer yeah and
Muller turned out to be the guy in the
wing just yeah and the guy that used to
do the Schlitz commercials broke it but
yeah we thought he was this guy of
wisdom and said cuz he didn't say
anything during the entire investigation
didn't he see an interview with him
nothing and then he comes out and you be
like oh no he's just another one of
these idiots like you see in Congress
and paraded in front of us to give these
interviews and he's like alright here's
what it was all about we didn't find him
guilty we didn't find him not guilty
first question isn't that your job
yeah and people don't seem to understand
what a prosecutor's job is especially
during an investigation like this it's
not a trial he is just getting
information too so the prosecution could
present the case there's no rebuttal
from a defense attorney or any rebutting
any of this evidence that he has so in
all of that in all those two years he
couldn't find anything he didn't find
anything but yesterday he had a pump out
a little bit of crap in his speech about
trumping the fact that he wasn't
sonna rated which means nothing in our
legal system right but try to tell
liberals what the legal system is about
is a whole other thing
well consent gotta send out a tweet yeah
yeah they don't even understand the most
basic of rights that we have in this
country right never mind understanding
prosecutorial ethics and and rules
whatever you're supposed to do so and
then the my favorite part of this whole
thing is watching the clowns the
candidates for the Democratic nomination
that are saying well it's clear as J
that he was saying that Congress now
needs to pick up the ball and and
immediately start impeachment proceeding
but nothing was clear by the way no
nothing at all your investigation has
ever been clear and don't you think they
have a motive they want Trump removed
because they cannot possibly beat him
it's like it's like every NFL team
wanting to impeach the Patriots the
season of course you're not gonna win so
they want to get rid of them so when you
hear any of these clowns talking about
Trump and how he needs to be impeached
there's an ulterior motive here right
they want to at least have somewhat of a
chance in in the presidential race and
it could backfire by the way if they try
to impeach him it could end up being
worse I know there are different
theories on that but I do wonder like
you said we really didn't hear from all
or a whole lot and so he sort of became
this kind of a Rorschach test he sort of
became this empty tablet that everyone
just kind of copied pasted onto him what
it did what they wanted well he hasn't
said anything therefore there's clearly
evidence and like you said when he came
out it wasn't clear but 30-something
million dollars later
how many subpoenas hundreds of subpoenas
and witnesses do you think you didn't
say anything during that time because he
was just at his desk going conference -
do I have to it's like you wake up you
haven't studied for the test and it's
the day of and if you go to over two
years with an investigation and you put
out this report that is supposedly
concise and has everything in it that
they they got as far as evidence and
interviews and testimony everything why
would he have to give the Democrats this
little hey
by the way guys I really mean impeach
him right nothing is in the report that
says this guy should be impeached
there's nothing in there that says he
committed any crimes right oh but
there's two but it doesn't say he didn't
oh geez
again our legal system does it rare sole
job was to determine whether he
committed crimes Muller and then passed
it along to someone who would be a
prosecutor he's a punk to Congress
wink wink what yeah then it becomes some
secret code in some nine minute speech
that he gave that all the Democrats and
and all these news channels of fake news
fake news seems so you see if they're
all back they see they they're the ones
that are now going crazy over everything
he said they're they're trying to decode
it yeah there's nothing to decode read
the report right that's all he said he
said the report is my testimony right
well it's kind of like the great you
know I don't expect everyone to read 400
something pages with the report but the
green New Deal is a great example of
that everyone was talking about in the
media we just read it on the channel we
just read it's five pages and that's by
the way printed in large font so we just
read it and immediately was demonetized
and restricted on YouTube just reading
the green new deal and I'm like Lesley
close to a million place because I think
we are just going to read it you know
that's all and it's so laughable all
right let me ask this you know Howard
Stern has been talking about this reason
and I want to get to him in a second
because he's been some interpreted as an
apology tour but he didn't sort of
lament the change in the media landscape
today from radio what it used to be with
having only callers and now today with
social media there's more sort of you
know scrutiny what's your opinion on
that you know I've sort of I did Fox
News and radio but not really this has
always been more so my middle year along
with with stand-up you were here for the
whole transition do you feel there's
more pressure if it was more freedom
well how would you compare it today when
I first got into radio they would sit
you down the GM the general manager the
PD program director they would sit you
down and say here are the FCC rules
here's our lawyers they will tell you
what the rules are and you must adhere
to
if you don't and there's a complaint we
have lawyers that will field all the FCC
it was always the FCC the Federal
Communications Commission drug
government those are the people you had
to worry about nothing else oh you'd get
some groups but for the most part if you
stayed within the lines you would be
okay but it was always they they
wouldn't complain directly if you upset
a gay group or a woman's group or or
anything minority group they would
complain to the FCC cuz that's what they
did right uh and and then you'd have to
field that complaint they were the
monster now it's everybody everyone is
now the FCC and can levy a fine on you
if I may use the word fine well you've
had actually quite Ellis knows Trudeau
Justin Trudeau wants to do that on
Twitter he wants the rest of the world
to follow Canada's hate speech
guidelines right yeah well we kind of
seemed pretty nuts with that whole thing
yeah order you leave your First
Amendment behind when you cross that
border going north but it's it's odd
because now the FCC is nothing when was
the last time you heard anybody that got
an FCC complaint on the radio it just
doesn't happen anymore that's true what
happens now is people get offended and
they start tweeting and getting in touch
with sponsors and they cut out the
entire FCC thing which actually used to
litigate with the station lawyers and
whatnot and they would actually discuss
First Amendment and things like that now
you're done and if you get some heat and
people enough people bitching complain
you're done you lose your career so you
think it's so you think it's worse now
than in the age of terrestrial radio it
is so much worse
we can't play some of the things we did
on regular FM radio back in the late 90s
on satellite radio we weren't allowed to
play it because it was too offensive
well in regular radio you know you know
the last time I got in trouble with the
FCC it wasn't really the FCC but this
was a terrestrially syndicated when it
was a podcast to I don't know like 20
summon stations not many and we were
putting on the podcast fake tornado
warnings you know that
well we'd have like Lena Dunham warnings
and Velociraptor warning so just like
fake sketches because we had a Phil
commercial breaks on podcast we were
sort of bridging this gap and we got an
email and someone from the station said
yeah they're not sure they know what's
your legal if you do it on air and radio
but you only inserted this into the
podcast portion but they want to see if
they need to treat it like us another
syndicating network and then I never
heard back from them so that was my
first and only experience with them yeah
they get upset with the emergency
announcements and I think that's what
the FCC is only handling now what they
were initially supposed to handle are
you broadcasting on the right frequency
is that the right power coming out of
the transmitter because they don't care
about content anymore and I think that
has to do with traditional terrestrial
radio stations don't put jocks on
anymore that do anything that could get
them in trouble right there so petrified
a personality driven radio now that they
just say shut up read the liners play
the music and that's it so you're not
getting that kind of controversial radio
anymore oh yeah I auditioned once for
national morning radio show this wasn't
that long it wasn't been Shapiro's old
house actually in and in his apartment
and they said we don't want you to
inject any personality just read the
news briefing it was the worst audition
ever I was so bad I walked out and I
swear my head was lost I didn't get it
and Ben I'm quite certain that I
embarrassed you for putting me up I'm so
sorry
if you didn't get if a Ryan Seacrest is
a Ryan Seacrest oh we do have to go let
me ask you this because this is some
contraband have you back to talk about
you know Howard Stern is bass your
newest book is out some people have said
it's kind of an apology tour where now
he's saying I shouldn't use words like
[ __ ] and he was a shock jock do you
think it's a natural evolution of a guy
who's no longer 28 or do you think it's
really more so based on acquiescing to
what's needed to survive like you were
just talking about there is absolutely a
growing phase that you go through and I
think when you you hit your 50s I guess
you really start thinking well
everything I did is fine but if I did it
now it would be pretty creepy right
especially where girls are involved he
did a lot of sexual stuff and right and
he was mean to a lot of celebrities but
it was hilarious for the listeners
but I understand growing out of that and
wanting to change your show maybe and
personality or whatever but you can't
disavow what you did right and you can't
take people like Gilbert Godfried who
were amazing on your show and kind of
built you up he had a lot of cast of a
lot of players that built him up to be
the Howard Stern he became and then to
just say well no we'll never have them
on again we'll never replay it will
never acknowledge we did that he was on
the view the other day and it was
hilarious just that he's on the view
yeah and one of the one of the Yente is
sitting next to him said something to
the effect of can you believe Howard
Trump rates women from one to ten and
Howard saying there I'm watching go -
have you watched his show where he took
a laser pen
yeah and had a nude woman standing in
front of him put it on her hip and went
well yeah little sad here honey that's a
good Howard lose a couple of pounds
there they have no idea and he doesn't
want anyone to really know that's who I
don't even think you know the Donald
Trump rated women on his show it was on
the show that right so I think he is
doing this apology tour if you get a
chance watch watch his appearance on
Jimmy Fallon tonight's show at the end
he wants to give away a book and they
show the camera open on Times Square and
he's able to talk to them on the big
billboard he led them in a sing-along
and dance along of the hokey-pokey with
zero irony I was mortified watching this
and growing up with Howard since he came
to NBC in 84 right watching that was one
of the saddest things I've ever seen so
yes you could change but that was kind
of like me with David Letterman him
about the last four years where I would
tune in and go oh man this is it's no
longer funny he's really really angry
and so far left that I can't do it and
it doesn't mean that he doesn't mean he
was not hilarious and groundbreaking
right I just was saying this is a season
where I'm going to have to ignore it
yeah yeah yeah yeah I don't know maybe
if it happens slowly it's almost like
the guy you're talking about in church
with a blonde hair yes all the sudden
Howard you know becomes it becomes this
guy that wants to be loved and apologize
to everybody it's just a little shocking
to is a true right time it's I'm not
going to use the word [ __ ] anymore
demean minorities like you had a [ __ ]
farting on a stripper yesterday
yesterday and it was an afternoon show
alright people can catch your show it's
compound media its compound media calm
calm yeah I come from 24 to 6 p.m.
Eastern Time
yeah Monday through Thursday and we have
a bunch of shows here on the platform so
yeah go to compound Mediacom give you
all the info you need absolutely
Pantelis is over hey mister come here
thank you so much for for being here and
I don't mind the moreno keep it up yeah
quest as we cross over the Red Sea we
find it the kingdom of the House of Saud
a place Allah referred to simply as home
a place that tells you to slow down
remember your prayers and to cover up
your neck head and upper and lower torso
a place where Sharia law ensures that
all men are men girls are girls who
can't drive and a God is all but a
distant vanished memory a place
somewhere over the sunset above the Red
Sea we hear the laughter of young boys
the lamentations of infidels in the
bleating of goats it's a place where the
number of public beheadings is surpassed
only by the funding of global terrorism
and gross abuse of basic human rights
pure Saudi Arabia
sponsored by Mohammed bin Salman in the
Tourism Board of Saudi Arabia louder
with broader Ranger pants while yours
today it louder with Crowder shop calm
what do we have here
it's Castle mug Club and it's mine not
so fast evil YouTube overlord David you
two can pitch Steven against YouTube
overlord playing for the power of castle
nut Club Oh No
YouTube is escaping Harper the battle
dog dad you saved the castle castle mug
club from the Masters of the internet
collection Steven and YouTube Overlord
each sold separately for more adventures
join my club at la de juez credit on
slash smuggler ninety-nine dollars
annually 69 for students veterans or
active military
[Music]
[Music]
it was like did you miss the movie uh I
just dropped my bearings there was
commando endorsee commando yeah some of
the commander Dornan Arnold was that
where he was in the swamp and he was
breathing through a reed that wouldn't
work no but do you know how I know it
wouldn't work because they thought I
would do a breathing contest an
underwater contest hold your breath cos
smartest with my brother and I cheated
by having a little blade of grass and I
lost the contest horribly I really
thought it would work just water
immediately just go straight just
immediately don't get enough through
that was it was more recently than I
would care to admit
yeah it was post moved to the United
States okay I thought I'd put one over
on him and I didn't thank you so much
again to Anthony Kamiya our apologies uh
Ted Cruz will be here I think was a June
something sometime soon and we'll keep
the move next week we have a bunch of
stuff coming I don't know what we have
we have we have some super videos all
right so this is one this is kind of
I'll get a little personal later on here
which is always tell it's always tough
to be kind of vulnerable in these
segments because you know it's the
internet like we just talked about with
Camila and most of you are terrible so
well he was talking about this we had
Daniel Cormier in the show was the
heavyweight champion in the world we've
had a lot of V Fermi talked about this
we have a lot of people who are
excellent in their field on the show and
we do the life advice segments a tough
love segments for those who are mug Club
members for those who aren't you know
it's a little bit of a longer show or we
just take some of your emails and try
and help people out most of the time we
don't but I noticed I've definitely
noticed a common thread and a question
that we get a lot is a lot of people
find themselves in a rut and I'll often
ask for the best way to find motivation
the best way to sort of find inspiration
to turn things around
so let me tell you're not gonna like
this here's the fact most sometimes it's
not there most of the time it's not
there and that's not to say that those
who find themselves in a rut or hopeless
far from it so follow me here a little
bit what about to offers is just the
probably the exact opposite of the
solution that you were hoping for but it
is a solution many people I think a lot
of folks in my experience I think that
successful people are very but by their
nature the rage
you know that's what we're taught to
believe they're driven they're motivated
all the time that's what makes them
elite when in reality and I've realized
some talking with people like Daniel
Corps Mayor Thomas Sol or Brian Shaw
anyone who's excellent um in really
these people just like you they often
don't feel motivated or inspired usually
it's the 80/20 rule successful people
are successful because they get up and
they do it anyway in spite of that and
again I've had the luxury of
interviewing the best of the best a
heavyweight champion of the world right
Brian Shaw four times world Strongest
Man
Thomas soul I don't know how many books
he's right after the first several dozen
I lose track and when I've asked any of
them what separates them from the pack
invariably they all answer and it might
surprise you it might not work ethic and
you know what here's one thing we're
talking about earlier this week there's
kind of a bell curve with talent when
you're young and you're playing sports
the sort of determining factor right is
talent at that point it really
determined it's determined by when you
add value how quickly you grow when you
hit your growth spurt that determines
whether you advance and in most
endeavors athletics academia thought I
was [ __ ] until I was in the fourth
grade turns out I just couldn't learn
geography and math and French thanks
Quebec government they still might think
my wife still thinks I could be [ __ ]
I'll get back to that there is a bell
curve though with town okay here a lot
that work ethic only takes you so far
and that's true but that talent is the
great divider is not necessarily true
particularly once you get past a certain
point let me give you for example I'm
never going to be able to jump like
LeBron James right why oh because I'm
not 6/8 with purely fast-twitch muscle
fibers this is not LeBron type okay you
would not catch me if I saw the
character breakdown it would not say
strong silent LeBron James type it would
be like maybe early James Cromwell type
early young Richard Jenkins type that's
what I would get I'd be a character side
character so yes let me get back to the
point there are divisions of talent okay
that's what takes to the center of the
bell curve now in this keep in mind I'm
applying the bell curve to professionals
to elites then something interesting
happens okay once you've weeded
everybody out and you're down to the top
1% of 1%
and that's usually what we're referring
to when we mean elite there's still a
gap there are still the NBA all-stars
for example the dream team and then
there's Michael Jordan there are still
top ranked heavyweight fighters in the
world who could beat anybody else in the
planet and then there's Daniel Cormier
who throws him around like a child
there's still world strongest men for
example second through 10th place and
then Brian Shaw wanting four years in a
row and the widening of the gap once you
get past that bell curve is no longer
due to talent it goes back goes it
reverses back to work ethic and I've
only realized this recently in having
enough of a sample size of interviewing
the elite of the elite and I would say
not only work ethic but work intellect
working smarter not just harder so many
people this is something we get so many
emails like this you know about this and
a life advice they're looking for the
sky's 2-part the light to shine down God
to show you your purpose or that moment
of inspiration motivation to hit you
sometimes it does okay and that's great
when it does sometimes it doesn't
there's a lot of variability I'll tell
you where there isn't a whole lot of
variability I'll tell you where there's
one constant while you were waiting for
your sign for your motivation there was
a guy or girl who wasn't there was a guy
who didn't feel like it
who wasn't motivated and he worked at it
anyway he wrote another book Thomas soul
he got another training session in
Daniel Cormier let me kind of explain
this because I want to preface this this
is something that's pretty personal but
I don't want what I'm about to say after
this to seem egotistical um I've kind of
alluded this before but I've I've
struggled with depression in my life
clinical depression it's been something
that's just been on my plate everyone
has their cross to bear not saying that
it's more of a burden or less of a
burden on other people I mean you know
I've talked about sort of the
fibromyalgia sand they go hand in hand
with a chronic pain but I tell you this
for two reasons okay people only bring
up number one depression or mental
health when a celebrity offs themselves
or when it's politically expedient to
discuss mental health care and needing
to D stigmatize it which ironically to
me makes it more stigmatized and by the
way to a degree it should in that it's
not a good thing it's not a good thing
to struggle with depression
I wouldn't wish it on anybody okay
but it does bother me when people come
on say oh yeah after Heath Ledger I
certainly struggled with it we need a D
Sigma ties it well let me ask this when
things aren't bad when there isn't some
famous celebrity who was taken - what
are you talking about it because that
makes it seem abnormal to people and
it's not a good thing people need help
they don't need to be coddled the
secretaries I bring this up not because
I'm elite or trying to say you could be
me too
but in you know what in the spirit of
objectivity we do a lot of content here
at this show and I guess by definition
being the top conservative Channel ever
makes us elite but that's only because
of the dearth of talent on the right you
know it's certainly nothing compared to
people like like John Oliver Jimmy found
we're grateful for everyone who Tunes in
but if I can toot the horn of the team
that intro that you saw today required
days of working on the song just writing
lyrics days of recording the song mixing
it then performing it was a lip-sync on
a green screen with a scratch track
hours of wardrobe makeup then days of
editing comping all the while I still
had to host and we've had to work on a
show four days a week and then some for
the last several weeks and this week we
were taping until midnight at in the
middle of a field covered in blood corn
syrup with mosquitos earnest to a
Goodfellas parody that you'll see next
week and then the workload starts again
so am i elite no but I'm at least as
accomplished as the next guy I will say
the team here of people as a unit I
would say they're elite and that's why I
break the clinical depression is
something I'm struggling with for a long
time so I bring up to show you that even
though I'm nothing necessarily special
what you see is a lot of work and I've
been doing it anyway so what you know
when you wake up and you don't feel like
it understand that's most people just do
something anything get out of bed get
out of your head and the reasons that
you're hearing through that nog and
telling you why not why you can't and
just do otherwise you will have to live
with for the rest of your life knowing
that while you were scrolling through
Pinterest looking for a motivating quote
and posters with kittens that say hang
in there there was that person out there
who was doing it in spite of having no
motivation at all and guess what that
person will be elite that person
invariably will be better than the rest
and if you don't follow that kind of vet
kind of a blueprint yourself that person
will be better than you and you'll have
to accept and it'll be able you'll make
all right see you next week
hope that helps
[Music]